chronique cinéma avec tanière bon
supporter ça comme tous les jeudis
tania un film attendu surtout c'est
amusant de parler de marseille 7e et
découvertes scientifiques à de l'eau
salée sur mars passé le film seul sur
mars exactement où des machines en
version originale en anglais nouveau
film de ridley scott qui nous a donné
une très longue filmographie mais entre
autres et oui on donc on y en ait dans
un terrain connu
cette fois ci on est dans un tout autre
univers créé de toute pièce on est sur
mars avec mad men qui incarne un
astronaute de la nasa qui abandonnée
parce que en fait tous ses collègues le
croit mort et donc il devra survivre et
à ce moment là et bien on n'a pas trouvé
encore l'eau sur mars
faire preuve d'ingéniosité et c'est un
botaniste de formation et va donc
trouver à travers des méthodes
scientifiques les façons tous rués à ce
niveau là c'est vraiment très
intéressant évidemment un convoi la
bande annonce
ça nous fait penser à interstellaire je
voudrais que c'est moins ésotérique que
ça et aussi des parallèles à faire avec
gravity je voudrais que c'est moins
poétique que ce soit mais dans
l'ensemble c'est très divertissant
vraiment et ce qui m'a surtout surpris
c'est que c'est très drôle là dessus
matt damon dans le rôle principal d'un
film tiré du livre de nba et qui comme
le dit mad men était très drôle
ce lundi c'était moins drôle sur le
plateau pour mad men parce qu'il a
tourné en plein désert de jordanie alors
des conditions extrêmes pour recréer
mars
il ya des moments où moi j' ai pas cru
je dois le dire mais bon comme c'est à
ce point divertissant je me suis
abandonnée en disant bon on va y croire
à cette planète mars
un film qui met aussi en vedette jessica
chastain vraiment il ya des rôles
secondaires très intéressant donc un
film qui prend l'affiché demain et c'est
rare que je dis somme je recommande la
version 3 d à
je n'en dis pas plus mais pour une fois
je trouve que une valeur ajoutée plus on
est mal
on analyse on l'a sûrement nous le bon
divertissement bref vous nous parlez
maintenant du festival international du
film black de montréal
oui ça donnait son rôle le festival
donné son coup d'envoi hier et ce soir
je vous recommande un film qui
présentait au quartier latin à 19h of
music and mind voici un extrait mais me
alors c'est un film qui raconte
l'histoire d'une femme en perte de
mémoire qui rencontre un spécialiste en
neurosciences et qui va tenter de faire
le lien entre la musique et la mémoire
ça s'inscrit dans une programmation qui
se poursuit jusqu'à dimanche et on a eu
quand même des invités de marque sont
venus à montréal pour l'occasion
notamment le fils de martin luther king
iii qui étaient là hier soir pour
recevoir le prix mais humanitaire et
demain on va rendre hommage au
scénariste et réalisateur paul haggis
qui a entre autres qui nous a donné
entre autres nos grandes heures de baby
et croches et des vélos qui lui est le
fondateur du festival en haïti alors je
vous le répète jusqu'à dimanche jusqu'à
dimanche et puis le 7 octobre la semaine
prochaine donc si un autre festival le
festival du nouveau cinéma qui commence
alors sortez vos agendas déjà pour vous
préparer la programmation a été dévoilée
cette semaine et on nous a dévoilé donc
le film d'ouverture
je vous laisse écouter un extrait parce
que vraiment c'est très très charmant
vous allez peut-être vous reconnaître
dans votre quotidien à vous ça
s'appellera le tout nouveau testament de
vote
quand on plonge le corps dans la
baignoire de téléphone sony loi de 1810
la fildak au qui avance toujours
d'écouter les gens qu'il connaît même
pas écouter me suis alors dans ce
nouveau testament avec benoît poelvoorde
qui est un dieu qui habite évidemment
bruxelles mais voilà ça vous arrive
sûrement d'être dans une file d'attenté
que selah sue celle d'à côté qui
avancent plus vite si on arrive à chaque
semaine une relecture dont du nouveau
testament de certains personnages
bibliques tout ça évidemment dans
l'humour avec entre autres catherine
deneuve et ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'on pourra voir plusieurs films
québécois qui ont été présentés dans les
festivals partout dans le monde mais pas
chez nous alors entre autres je vous
invite à voir en dehors fine d'andré
turpin il ya aussi les êtres chers les
démons bref la liste est longue allée
voir la programmation complète sur le
web
merci tu as bien fait bonsoir